medical shows have long been a staple of
prime time television
as the life and death stakes combined
with the toll the job takes on doctors
and nurses can make for gripping dramas
shows such as er house and grey's
anatomy
have all highlighted the heartache and
humanity at the core
of every healthcare emergency tragically
though for the hit series new amsterdam
the medical drama has become
all too real resulting in the sudden and
shocking departure
of one of its biggest stars airing on
nvc
new amsterdam follows the travails of a
new medical director
and the head of several hospital
departments at america's oldest public
hospital
as they try to move past stifling
bureaucracy to keep the focus on
patients
the hit show is based on the book twelve
patients life and death at bellevue
hospital
by eric mannheimer the all-star ensemble
cast of the show
includes performers such as ryan eggold
frema ageman
and tyler levine in the main cast but
one of the most important stars was
luminary indian performer
anupam kerr kerr who is best known to
american audiences for his role in
silver linings playbook
is one of india's most famous actors
having appeared
in more than 500 films on new amsterdam
kerr played dr vijay kapoor who was the
focal point of a major storyline in
season 3
after the character contracted coven 19
and disappeared into isolation in the
season's second episode
much of the early part of the season
then revolved around his illness
in the attempts by the hospital staff to
ensure he survives and regains his
health
however in the season's seventh episode
which aired april 13th
the staff was shocked to learn that dr
kapoor would not be returning to new
amsterdam hospital
at all as he instead resigned vijay's
doctor told him he's never going to work
again
um about a month ago as surprised as the
characters on the show
were fans were even more surprised to
learn that kerr was actually leaving the
show for good
and had been written out at his own
request why
sadly the answer is even more tragic
than any plot line on new amsterdam
anupam kerr's wife kiran kur is a
well-known performer and politician
in her own right on april 1st 2021
anu pomker revealed on twitter that his
wife had been diagnosed with multiple
myeloma
which is also known as collars disease
multiple myeloma
is a rare type of blood cancer that
affects plasma cells
a type of white blood cell found in bone
marrow unfortunately
there is yet no known cure for multiple
myeloma
but with early detection and treatment
it can potentially become dormant for
long periods of time
anupamker's statement which was made in
conjunction with his son
sikander reads in part she is currently
undergoing treatment and we are sure she
will come out of this
stronger than before we are very blessed
that she's being looked after by a
phenomenal set of doctors
she's always been a fighter and takes
things head-on she's all heart and
that's why she has so many people that
love her
so keep sending your love to her in your
prayers and in your heart
two weeks later tv insider reported that
cursed parcher from new amsterdam would
be permanent
and on april 27th kerr tweeted another
statement to fans
reflecting on his time as dr vijay
kapoor on
new amsterdam this past year has been
difficult for so many people around the
world
not least for dr kapoor it was an
incredibly special time for me to be
part of this show
and one i will never forget the new
amsterdam family will always hold a
special place in my heart
i am grateful to the audience for their
love support and good wishes
particularly for my wife kieran at this
time
i hope you all will continue to join me
on my journey
and future projects here's wishing the
whole kerr family the best of luck
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one